Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
Wandavision episode 7 video welcome to the
agatha show so obviously there were a bunch of
big reveals but they also raised a bunch of big
questions they didn't completely answer everything
but there were a ton of easter eggs so much stuff
that we have to break down so many wtf moments if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the episodes i'm doing videos for all
the marvel disney plus series this year falcon
and winter soldier is going to be up next right
after Wandavision ends but careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet because they do
reveal a bunch of really big information i'll just
start at the beginning and then we'll work our way
through the episode shot by shot as we talk about
big reveals wtf moments and easter eggs and what
i think is really going on with agatha harkness
welcome to the show agatha harkness they basically
confirmed my agatha harkness theory i think after
they announced the series i think my first
theory for who katherine hahn was playing
way back last year was act of the harkness just
because she was so connected to scarlet witch in
the comics but the real question is is who is she
working for so i'll talk about that later in the
video because it is implied that she is serving
a greater master she's kind of like a version
of kaiselius who was surfing dormammu but who is
ak at the harkness serving i did a trailer video
talking about all the nightmare easter eggs on the
show so far and how it seems like they're implying
he might play a role in this so i'll link that
at the end of this people got weird when i posted
that too i think they didn't realize that marvel
had dropped a trailer and they thought that i was
doing an episode video early because it was for
episode 7. no that was not a spoiler that was a
trailer video that marvel posted on their channel
generally anything that marvel releases before
episodes come out are not considered spoilers
because they want that information to be public
but the episode starts with that big modern
family parody cold open scene of scarlet
witch waking up the next day after having changed
everything to the 2010s the twins of the same ages
uncle pietro is nowhere to be found no quicksilver
anywhere to be found seemingly when she changed
everything she dismissed him the way she dismisses
people when she changes everything overnight
we find out what's happening with him in
the post-credits scene or mid-credit scene
it wouldn't be a marvel event if there wasn't
a mid-credit scene so if you turn the episode
off after it hit the credits you missed a pretty
big reveal don't worry i'll talk about that in a
second and what i think is going on with this
character because that does answer a bunch of
big questions about what's going on with him i
love some of the details as they start showing
you how things are glitching out billy and tommy
are playing video games they have the gamecube
controllers but when things glitch out they
go back to the atari controllers the uno cards
the twins are a little bit like vision in that
they can't be controlled completely by scarlet
witch and they have this understanding of the way
things work in the hex that other people do not
there are a lot of good billion timing moments in
the episode but they're really only in the first
part of the episode you notice vision's pillowcase
has hexes all over it like the shape of the hex
that they're in right now but also wanda's paisley
pillow seems like it's a pair of eyes staring down
on her which i think is good foreshadowing for the
reveal at the end of the episode that people have
been watching her this whole time agatha harkness
has been watching her this whole time along with
whoever she's been serving whichever greater
marvel cosmic villain if you go back and you watch
a lot of the older episodes too anytime you see
people being weird watching her in the background
retroactively now we can go back and watch those
and say oh they were clearly trying to foreshadow
this big reveal that she was being watched this
whole time billy also tells her that his head
starts hurting it's noisy because this is a very
big professor x x-men easter egg his powers are
getting more and more powerful and he's starting
to pick up the thoughts of other people in town
i think this is all just developing his character
i don't know if they're going to turn them into
teenagers by the end of the show or if they're
going to wait to recast them with older versions
to when they show up in future marvel projects i
think they're going to stay mostly with the young
versions for the rest of the episodes because of
the way they're probably going to end the series
i think they're going to be going for the classic
comic book easter eggs where she has to say
goodbye to them temporarily but then they find a
workaround and they're able to keep the children
alive for future cameos when they're adults for
young avengers stuff i feel like they completely
nailed the modern family parody in this cold open
scene elizabeth olsen is doing an amazing version
of the mom from modern family like she pulls the
covers back and reveals that she's still wearing
the scarlet witch outfit from the halloween
costume then for about the first 10 minutes
of the episode they still play it modern family
where she comes down she kind of tries to avoid
them she's wearing her pajamas like i'm going
to stay in my pajamas for the rest of the day if
possible then they do the big joke with the milk
and things start glitching out around you they
don't completely explain why they're glitching out
but it's tied to scarlet witch's mental state and
the fact that she's slowly breaking down there
are several references to her going crazy in the
episode going cuckoo for coco puffs as agatha
harkness says it's all part of the house of m
storyline that they're adapting her slowly losing
her mind there is a bit of a funny easter egg
for all the sword stuff that was happening in the
episode like you have the circus on the outskirts
of town that didn't wind up being as big of a
plot point as i expected it to be they played
it mostly for just a one-off joke but when she
grabs the cereal you notice that there's a clown
on the front of the box which is just a reference
to the circus then as they keep doing the milk
carton joke with it switching between different
versions you notice that there's a missing kid ad
on the back so i think this is going to be bigger
in the finale and it sounds like some easter eggs
that we've seen from the set of spider-man 3 about
quote-unquote missing children so it sounds like
they're laying seeds for stuff that they're going
to spill into doctor strange 2 and spider-man 3.
this could be the beginning of a much larger
storyline that they're laying track work for
and i know a lot of you were hoping that because
they were doing the modern family parody were
also in the 2010s they would do a parody of the
office tv show that's basically what the new intro
was the new version of the theme song even sounded
like the theme song from the office but you notice
that all the different logos and labels just have
wanda all over it we're all wanda so they keep
making all these references making you think that
the hex is all about wanda revolving around her
which i think is just set up for the payoff of
the act of the hardness reveal where we find out
that it's actually been active the harkness that
everything has been revolving around this whole
time like wanda is not the center of the universe
don't worry i'll talk about the commercial too
because i think the nexus commercial is also a big
part of act of the harkness's plan then we jump
back to the sword base and tyler hayward they're
set up eight miles outside of town obviously there
isn't a whole lot going on with him during the
episode they just want to set up the idea that
he's got some big ploy that he's going to burn
westview to the ground so to speak to try and
get vision back and we do get confirmation on his
plan to turn vision into a new weapon but we also
find out that there's no tv signal coming back
out so basically no more tv show being broadcast
at this point then because his storyline is all
about vision they jumped to vision waking up in
the field right where he went down in episode six
right outside the old sword base which has been
turned into the circus all the sword agents are
in character of circus performers including darcy
who they reveal is the escape artist which is a
bit of a funny reference to her literally trying
to escape the hex once vision wakes her up so to
speak but they played for comedy and you remember
that kat dennings has been on sitcoms a lot so
she's actually a pro at doing this kind of parody
i do love some of the jokes that they have between
them like she thinks that vision is trying to pick
her up eventually she finally says yes like okay
fine i'll go on a date with you but i'm ordering
the lobster then they sort of continue the modern
family parody of the episode with the way they
film things they do all the cut to's with them
talking directly to camera they drive off in
the funnel cake truck after she clocks the strong
man and then she basically narrates the story of
the mcu what happened during avengers infinity
war so wait a minute wanda killed me why would
she do that well because you asked her to to save
the universe well technically half of the universe
i love the way they keep doubling down on it too
did it work well it worked for a minute till the
villain rewound time and killed you himself
but don't worry they got there in the end just
a couple extra steps to get there though but the
whole idea here is that vision is starting to come
back around on wanda like he was really pissed
off at her and then they have all these jokes
about her creating barriers to slow him down so
that he won't get home faster but he is starting
to understand how she feels the pain that she
felt having to watch him die twice so i think
it's all in service of the big act of the hardness
payoff revealing that she's kind of the villain of
the series right now and they're all going to
have to unite together against her eventually
like right now they're all kind of fighting
amongst themselves but they need to come together
like even monica rambeau had to fight wanda
briefly for a second but they'll have to work
together to defeat agatha harkness then we watch
scarlet witch slowly have a full-blown mental
breakdown in front of the twins she opens the door
without saying anything with her powers agatha
harkness walks in on cue then she greets her now
i'm kind of thinking because agatha the hardness
was pulling the strings from afar that act of
the harkness was mind controlling scarlet witch
a little bit at least on a low level she would
just implant the idea in scarlet witch's head
and then she would think that she wanted something
and then use that as a cue to just barge right in
the funny thing though about her offering to
babysit she's like i really did bite a kid once
now i'm thinking she really did do that that's
not just a wtf joke because they play her is so
sinister when they do the reveal at the end of
the episode but then as she takes the twins away
scarlet witch tries to chill for just a hot
second until everything starts flipping out
and glitching all over the place around her so the
important thing to remember is that wanda is still
technically controlling things inside the hex but
she's kind of being emceed on the dl by akatha
harkness so i think the reason why active harkness
is magic is purple is so that you can tell who is
using their powers at any given time so when you
see the red energy it's scarlet witch doing things
when you see purple energy exactly the hardness
doing things but then outside town monica rambeau
and jimmy wu get darcy's email about project
cataract they learn all about what hayward was
doing with vision it basically confirms all of
our theories i think we all suspected that he
was trying to turn vision into a weapon and that
was what was happening when scarlet witch came to
rescue his body not necessarily steal it probably
rescue it and obviously i think they're trying to
imply that it has something to do with the powers
of the hex and her magic reanimating his dead body
because at the end of the episode even darcy
when they're talking about it like what am i now
what's going on they're not able to answer the
question of why he's not able to leave the hex
fully they haven't explained that question yet and
i think the reveal is is that he's secretly still
dead and he's more of like a puppet that she's
animating like i've been making the weekend of
bernie's jokes but it really is a weekend to
bernie situation that's also why she probably
doesn't want her children to leave the hex either
because she's worried that they'll either break
down or they'll die outside of her power but they
also do the reveal of who that secret engineer was
that monica rambeau kept talking about and it's a
bit of a letdown it's actually major goodner who
is not a comic book character i couldn't find any
marvel references to that name she just seems like
a totally new character they created for the tv
show they played it like a really big thing they
hyped it up big time so i'm a little disappointed
but it's not that big a deal i knew it was not
going to be some big fantastic four moment they're
not going to do that kind of a reveal on the tv
show like this i was really holding out hope for
adam brashear the blue marvel but there's always a
chance they could introduce him in captain marvel
2 or one of the other mcu movies the big thing
here though is that they put her in that space
suit and they send her back in in that craft but
she finds out that she just has to push her way
back in and part of the reason why she can do that
probably has to do with her already being modified
her dna being mutated quote unquote so to speak
making more x-men references by the hex itself
when she pushes through they basically show you
what is a version of her comic book origin story
she sort of separates out into all the different
versions that you've seen from the different
eras she starts hearing flashback voices from her
mother dialogue from the captain marvel movie of
captain marvel speaking to her all these different
voices speaking to her as she's basically getting
a version of her comic book powers when she comes
out she's crackling with blue energy and she's
wearing a version of her white comic book costume
the thing here though is that when she comes
out you see her eyes crackling with blue energy
and she seemingly sees more of the electromagnetic
spectrum like she can see magic and things flowing
around all over the place the artificial construct
of the hex itself the nature like she's seeing the
matrix the way that neo sees the matrix in
those movies i think that's an easter egg
for her spectrum powers like the electromagnetic
spectrum but she's had a bunch of different comic
book names so i feel like they're just going for a
combination of easter eggs for all those different
versions of her comic book character so she's
been spectrum she's been a version of photon she
was even a version of captain marvel before carol
danvers became captain marvel i'll talk more about
her powers in a second because they kind of break
up the reveals through the episode but you do see
her kind of use her powers at least on a low level
but she doesn't understand how they work yet but
clearly she has her abilities one of the funniest
moments though like after the stork comes back
from episode three even the story comes back is
when she starts talking to the phantom person the
phantom voice off of camera like she talks about
how she's losing control she doesn't understand
why she's not able to do what she wants to do then
this mysterious voice off of camera says do you
think maybe this is what you deserve and it's so
meta because i think it's obviously set up for the
big reveal of back of the harness like you see her
literally sitting in the director's chair which is
more of a metaphor than a literal thing because
technically nobody else is inside the room with
her when this is happening so the voice that she's
speaking to is kind of like a magical voice that's
manifested by the hex the hex is generating this
sort of hollow like simulation for her but it's
agatha the hardness that's pulling the strings so
it's kind of like act of the harkness is the one
that's speaking to her saying that i just love
the way they play it though and then they go
to the commercial and obviously it's a parody for
antidepressants they talk about feeling depressed
and then prescribe this nexus drug so to speak but
i think the idea is the nexus is a place like you
talk about nexuses of the multiverse nexuses in
space and time the ad talks about it anchoring you
to your reality or any reality that you want to
go to so clearly it's a big multiverse easter egg
like we're talking about full-blown doctor
strange too multiverse of madness stuff here they
even mention a doctor prescribing things which i
think is just another reference to doctor strange
so even though they raise more questions than
they answer i think they're just trying to lay the
track work for explaining how the multiverse as a
concept is tied to what's happening with the hex
as well as what ag of the harkness is doing
and maybe the people that she's working with or
working for i'll talk about that in a second too
because they imply some really heavy cosmic stuff
at the end of the episode i do love some of the
jokes that they lay in there too obviously there's
a bunch of big wtf reveals but they talk about the
side effects feeling your feelings seizing your
truth also causes more depression and when they
talk about the doctor clearing you to move on with
your life i think either that's a reference for
doctor strange showing up in the finale clearing
wanda so to speak to move on with her life because
everything that's happened so far they also lay
in the joke about the world not revolving around
you which is more setup for the ag of the hardness
reveal because technically the world of the
hex has kind of been revolving around her this
whole time then we go back to agatha hardness's
house with the twins and they sort of sit down i
love the way that the twins play with her just a
little bit like billy says i like it here because
you're quiet on the inside now that's just his
powers slowly starting to manifest because he
can't read her thoughts because we learned
that she has power just like doctor strange
she's a sorceress so she can block herself or
protect herself from people reading her thoughts
but you look around her house and all the scenes
especially when she's speaking to camera look at
some of the patterns on her furniture they remind
you of some of the patterns that show up during
the doctor strange movie obviously just more
foreshadowing that they pay off at the end of
the episode but also just in general her entire
house looks like it was decorated by a witch
she also references her husband ralph again we
haven't heard about ralph in a while part of me
wants to believe that ralph is going to wind up
being the bigger marvel cosmic villain that she's
serving like if we're talking about kaiselius
dormammu references who is it that she is really
serving that we have a couple more funny moments
with darcy and vision and him going through the
rest of his backstory trying to re-learn
about what happened to him so you're saying
that i started out as jarvis this artificial
intelligence and then my body was created by
ultron for the purposes of genocide what am i
supposed to be now and obviously she doesn't have
any answers for him like i i don't know they also
had that joke about evan peters quicksilver too
what was going on with the false version of pietro
and she's also like i have no idea same thing with
scarlet witch when the twins ask her what was the
deal with uncle pietro she's like you know what
i don't have all the answers that's just the
writers of the show letting us know we're
not going to reveal everything probably until the
finale but i think based on the post-credit scene
or the mid-credit scene we have a lot more clues
about what's really happening with this character
clearly in league with agatha harkness so
i'll talk more about him in a second too
monica rambeau has her big confrontation with
scarlet witch trying to tell her the truth
about what's happening with hayward and vision
and sword you have to stop him or he's going to
burn the x to the ground and make you seem like
it was all your fault and you're the villain
when she says maybe i am the villain that's just
a reference to comic book scarlet witch sort of
going off the rails we haven't quite got there yet
because clearly agatha harkness comes to take her
away before monica can talk her down but they do
have that moment where she just briefly uses her
powers without kind of realizing what's going on
they even have that full-blown gunslinger standoff
moment where she's like come at me bro that feels
like they're going to pay that off in the finale
like you'll actually see monica rambeau really
use her powers but after agatha the hardness takes
scarlet witch back to her house she kind of starts
looking around realizing that something's not
quite right everything just gets really creepy she
notices the uneaten sandwiches and drinks where
are the boys oh they're in the basement playing
the creepiest basement you've ever been into
you are definitely not going to get tortured down
there it was pretty clear that agatha harkness
said that they were playing in the basement just
so that scarlet witch would go to the basement
where she could get her alone to mind control her
again but did you actually wonder what did she do
with the twins the other clue i think for what's
going on with agatha the hardness is when she's
sitting down there too she looks at the tv you see
a children's show playing but in the children's
show you see a bunch of creatures dancing like
this one eye creature a bunch of other big looking
monsters it's meant to be their parody of yo gabba
gabba which is an actual television show in real
life those might represent the people that agatha
harness is working for the cosmic marvel villains
like when she does go down into the basement
and starts walking around inside out of the
harnesses lair you see all these emblems embedded
in the ceiling which probably represent different
big marvel cosmic villains that she serves
maybe it's a version of the marvel elder gods
that gets into characters like catholic but we
also have characters like nightmare mephisto
the other marvel fearlords she could be working
for then there's a very powerful looking book of
dark magic it looks like something right out of
doctor strange's sanctum this is more the doctor
strange two multiverse of madness connection like
you're talking about doctor strange level magic
like she comes in and reveals herself you didn't
think you were the only magic user in town did you
i've seen a couple theories about what that book
might be though a lot of people wondering if it's
a version of the darkhold i don't think it is
i think it's another book but it's meant to be
just as ancient and just as bad and powerful
as the darkhold you also notice when she walks
in and reveals herself there's a carving of a
devil face and the pillar right behind her that
doesn't necessarily mean she's serving mephisto
it seems like she's serving a number of different
older marvel gods or marvel cosmic villains like
we're talking dormammu shumagoroth just think big
evil doctor strange villains then they just end
the episode with her mind controlling scarlet
witch again and then playing the real version of
the intro like the agatha version of the intro as
if we've been secretly watching the agatha show
this whole time which is a bit of a twist on the
intro for this episode which had wanda's name all
over it making you believe that it was all about
her when really it's been about agatha this whole
time they play through the decades they reveal
that she was behind pretty much every big wtf
twist every moment even behind the false version
of quicksilver so they are sort of positioning
agatha harkness as the main villain of Wandavision
right now but it seems like she is working
for more powerful characters catherine hahn's
performance as agatha harkness so far on the show
has been amazing she's done a great job of just
bouncing back and forth between all the different
iterations of her character that she needed to be
for any given episode like if she needed to
be more comedic or the nosy neighbor persona
then the turn to full-blown agatha harkness when
she revealed herself as a sorceress like oh no
i am the danger here i think it's pretty clear
that they're hyping up a full-blown wizard battle
between scarlet witch and act at the harkness in
the finale i can't wait to see what that looks
like the closest thing we've really gotten to
that so far has been an avengers infinity war
where you have thanos going at doctor strange with
both of their full powers and a couple infinity
stones but i think this is why they've been
hyping up how powerful scarlet witch really is
so that when they pay this often whatever their
big final battle winds up being it just looks
spectacular then hopefully you stay for the
credits because this is a marvel event they
finally have a big credit scene and it's monica
rambeau trying to enter agatha harkness's basement
seeing all this purple magic radiating out
like she's in the middle of casting this spell
but she gets caught by evan peters character who's
wearing this weird tie-dye shirt who says snoopers
going to snoop then you only see the reaction
on monica's face and her eyes sort of glaze
over with purple energy making it seem like evan
peters character also has magical abilities just
like agatha harknesses like wherever she gets
her magic from whichever big marvel villain he
also gets it from that place too so this doesn't
confirm who he is but they did go very far during
the episode to say that he was not their uncle
so he's not meant to be mcu quicksilver he does
look mysteriously like peter maximoff from
the fox marvel universe in the x-men movies
so i know people are wondering if there's going
to be a multiverse twist with this character
that's also still possible but it does seem
like he is a magic user working with agatha
harkness so you just have to remember to work
that into what your theory is but everybody post
all your theories in the comments below now who
do you think evan peter's character is playing
i don't think that he's playing mephisto i don't
think he's playing nightmare i think it's somebody
a little bit smaller than that but it'll probably
wind up being a bit of a marvel easter egg
marvel will start revealing more about what was
actually going on during the episode two so i'll
be doing more bonus videos this week for some of
the bigger wtf moments and plot points leave all
your big questions in the comments below and if
you did spot any really big easter eggs that i
didn't mention in the video just write them below
in the comments we got two more episodes left and
paul bettany said that the special cameo scene
that he was hyping up earlier has not happened yet
kind of confirming our theory that it's probably
going to happen in the finale so leave all your
theories about that too but everyone click here
for my brand new Wandavision nightmare video
sort of breaking down all the nightmare easter
eggs and click here for all my other Wandavision
episode videos thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!